que el número debe reemplazar al bueno a
este circuito con una equis adentro
de abajo y tenemos esta ecuación de aquí
que dice 84 es igual a 4 más y bueno
aquí tengo otra vez este circuito que
estoy buscando este circuito curioso y
lo que quiero que observemos de aquí es
lo siguiente mira si tengo 84 es igual a
esto sería exactamente lo mismo esa es
la propiedad conmutativa de la suma es
una forma elegante de decir que bueno no
sé en 84 es igual a 4 más 8 no importa
que el número esté después del signo más
o quien esté antes entonces si 84 es lo
mismo que 48 entonces este circulito
curioso con un tacha dentro puede
reemplazarse por el número 8 y esa va a
ser mi respuesta así que déjenme quitar
este de aquí y ahora vamos a hacer este
de aquí que dice que el número debe
reemplazar al y bueno esta vez tengo
esto que parece una cruz
pequeña daga de abajo y luego tengo 10
más 4 en paréntesis 3 es igual a esta
pequeña cruz más 4 3 en paréntesis
entonces lo que esta vez nos está
pidiendo es que no nos importe si
primero tomamos la suma de 10 más 4 y
después le sumamos 3 o primero tomamos
la suma de 4 3 y después le sumamos 10
lo que dice este enunciado de aquí es
que si cambiamos el paréntesis y lo
pongo primero en el 43 porque voy a
hacer esta operación primero es lo que
está en paréntesis entonces no importan
porque este número que tengo aquí va a
ser justo el 10 esto es simplemente la
propiedad asociativa de la suma o dicho
de otra manera la suma es asociativa y
entonces esta pequeña cruz esta pequeña
cruz que tengo que va a tomar el número
no importa si sumas primero 10 más 4 y
después de sumas 3 o si primero sumas 4
3 y después le sumas 10
entonces esto será el 10 y bueno déjame
quitar esto de aquí porque quiero que
hagamos uno más vamos a hacer este para
finalizar y dicen que el número debe
reemplazar al y bueno esto se parece al
símbolo de se prohíben porque lo ponen
justo encima de un cigarro y entonces
significa que se prohíbe fumar pero
bueno me refiero este círculo con una
línea diagonal adentro y tengo bueno 9 x
6 es lo mismo que 6 x y aquí tengo otra
vez este símbolo este círculo con la
diagonal adentro pero la multiplicación
también es conmutativa es decir 9 por 6
va a ser lo mismo que 6 por 9 entonces
este círculo con la diagonal aquí se
puede reemplazar por el 9 y ya con esto
hemos acabado